Ben burada olmak çok güzelmiş Herkese
merhaba izleyen Herkese selamlar 1984 O
ağrı doğumluyum Ağrı'nın Diyadin
ilçesine bağlı küçük bir köye sabah Saat
beşe doğru Hava soğuk mu soğuk Hani
derler ya Hava kurşun gibi ağır Tam da
öyle bir günde taş evin bir metreyi
bulan taş evin içinde hayat adeta acı ve
Tatlı yüzünü gösteriyordu O bir yandan
yeni babalarını kaybetmiş genç kızların
ve onların annelerinin çığlığı Diğer
yandan Henüz yeni anne olmuş sevincini
ve hüzünü içine atan bunu gösteremeyen
genç annenin sessiz çığlığı Ben geldim
dercesine ağlayan bebeğin sesi adeta
bu dengeyi bozuyordu ve bir yandan da
hayattan Umut Allah'tan umut kesilmez
sözcüğünün Aslında vücut bulduğu bir
yerde O ev babaannemin adımı ilk koyduğu
yerde orası bu duygularla bu
düşüncelerle Bu evin içinde böyle geldim
dünyaya ve böyle başladı hikaye o Umut
sen misin yani Umut benim aslında o Umut
hikayesi ile başlayan hikayenin oluştuğu
evde Doğan Umut benim dediğim gibi 1984
doğumluyum ve küçük aile işletmesinde
minnacık bir yufka dükkanın tezgahında
başlayan hayata atılma sürecim beni
buralara getiren sürecim Aslında böyle
başladı Baba annem bana hep Umut sadece
senin adın değil derdi Umut senin ta
kendin derdeğe bu bahsettiğim süreç al
ve elektriğin bile daha olmadı günlerden
bahsediyoruz sanırım 1991 yılıydı ilk
ışıkla tanışmam e düğmeye dokunup
elektriğin geldiğini görünce gazete
satan çocuklar gibi koşarak sokağa
fırlamıştı ve 7 yaşlarında yaydım
ortalama altı buçuk yedi yaşlarında
yaydım Elektrik geldi diye bağırarak
sokağa fırlamıştı mım küçük aile
işletmesinin tezgahında başlayan Hikayem
beni buralara ve Kordon bile kadar
götürdü aslına bakarsanız Kordon mutfak
ve pastacılık mezunuyum uzun yıllar
Avrupa'da birçok şehirde çalıştım
Londra'da Yaşadığım bir süre e dünyanın
farklı ülkelerinde farklı iş konseptleri
yaptım yerine içmek üzerine ama hep şuna
inandım Anadolu bir paylaşım kültürü
deryası ve ben o Derya'nın hem mutfağına
hem de kültürüyle büyümüş biri olarak
Fransız Mutfağı mezunuz olsam kendi
mutfağımı yapmalıydım Aslında hikaye
öyle başla
bu ne döndüğümde doğduğum yere geri
döndüm Fransız Mutfağı eğitimi alıp
kendi döndürüp doğduğum topraklara geri
dönmem böyle başladı Tabii ki bir insan
eğer Anadolu mutfağı kültürüyle
büyüyorsa ve Anadolu mutfağı ve
Anadolu'nun kendi kültüründe
harmanlandığı ysa dünyaya ve çevresine
duyarsız kalması Bunu görmezden gelmesi
mümkün değil de bu duyarlılık da Aslında
bugün burada olmamı sağlayan şey çünkü
biz böyle bir kültürde büyüdük ve
kimseye duyarsız kalamazdık paylaşım
kültürü hem büyüdüğüm iş alanında
mesleğim oldu Hem doğduğum yerde
hayatımın bir parçası oldu bu yüzden de
bir şeyler yapmalıyız diyerek o
duyarlılık beni burada olmama ve Sanki
ben de kalkıp ojesini Aslında oluşturan
şey şimdi Proje geçmeden önce bir şey
daha sana soracağım Senin o Kadıköy'deki
güzel küçük restoranında güzel güzel
yemek yerken sana
bu anlatmıştın hatırlıyor musun annenle
ilgili annenin ilk galiba İstanbul'a
geldiğinde yaşadığınız bir olay bir
arkadaşımız Anadolu'da bilirsiniz
Aslında belki de ben bunu yaşayan ya da
öğrenerek gören ilk sonra Selim
bilirsiniz ki oralarda insanlar
evlerinin kapılarını kapatma zlar
insanlar kimseye sırtlarını Dönmezler
Annem de İstanbul'a geldiğinde Yerde
yatan birini gördük herhalde bir yerde
Beyoğlu'nda ya ben çok alıştım artık
hepimiz çok Alışırız İstanbul'da yaşayan
birileri olarak Tabiki birde Londra'da
vesaire daha çok görmüştüm e farkında
bile değilim annem dedi ki orada bir
yatıyor Evet anne dedim Onu almamız
lazım dedi anne alamayız dedim burada
böyle biraz dedim ey kadın o şoku
atlatamadı Biz bayağı yürüdük ileriye
doğru büyüdükçe dönüp arkasına baktı
baktı ve ve o adam orada mı kalacak dedi
Ben o gün aslında ne kadar değerli bir
toprak parçası
Evet şimdi büyüdüğümüzü ne kadar değerli
bir nesil olduğumuzu fark etmiştim o da
öyle ismi yaralayan aslında başka bir
hikaye Peki sonra sonra de mi geldi
çattı dükkanların kepekleri kapandığı
şimdi biraz Ondan sonrasını anlatacağım
ve karşı penceredeki Tabii ki teyzeyi
soracağım sana ya şöyle Biz pandomimle
duyuyorduk biliyorsunuz işte Hatta
oralar Biz de çok daha rahatlık ve
birdenbire Türkiye'de de Tan zeminin
ayak sesleri duyulmaya yakında
hissetmeye başladığımız ilk günlerde
Evet at diye böyle bir gün pazar günü
zaten dükkan kapalıydı ederler ki
pazartesi günü itibariyle dükkanlar
kapanacak Benim de yine bu paylaşımı
anlatan paylaşım kültürünü anlatan bir
restoranın bu tada İstanbul Kadıköy
Moda'da göç anlamına gelen bir ismi var
Biz dükkan açıldı zaten Bir buçuk sene
oldu işte Londra'dan döndüm dükkan açtık
derken
Şu Karşı binamızda yani sokakta tam
karşımızda devamlı en alt katta oturan
bir teyzemiz var Ben pencereyi her sabah
açar Hatta Açmazsa biz merak ederiz ilk
günlerde itibariyle hep böyle Bizi
izlemeye başladı Bir gün beni yanına
çağırdı dedi ki ilk buraya açtınız dedi
neden dedim Dedi ki ben her gün size
bakıyorum ve çok mutlu oluyorum dedi Biz
böylece bir bağ kurduk her gün İşte biz
ona kahve yapıyoruz yemek yapıyoruz o
bizden bir şey istiyor dondurma istiyor
çocuklardan falan derken bir ilişkimiz
oldu teyze de burada pencerede her gün
görürdük bir şekilde sonra pandemi geldi
çattı değiller ki dükkanlar kapandı ve
Ben hayatım boyunca çok çalışmış Çok
gezen hiç durmayan günübirlik Londra'ya
gidip gelen bir insan olarak ben ne
yapacağım şimdi ya dedim Benim bir şey
yapmam lazım Ben öyle duramam et abi bir
yandan da birilerine yardım etmek her
zaman kültürel doku larımız da var
birilerine de yardım etmemiz
de bunun üstüne çok sevdiğim gazeteci
bir arkadaşım var sevgili bir erkeğe Ona
da selam olsun burada Evi aradım Dedim
ki Ebru Benim aklımda bir şey geçiyor
çünkü ben Almanya'da staj yaparken şöyle
bir şey görmüştüm orada bir mahalle
örgütlenmesi var ve Mahalleli gençler
orada yaşlı insanların hem Pazar hem
Market alışverişlerini yapıp götürüp
evlerine teslim ediyorlar eve o günden
beri hep aklımda bu bir şekilde yer
etmişti ya ne kadar güzel bir kültür
demiştim Çünkü birlerine bir şey yapmak
Bazen çok küçük de gözükse çok önemli
aslında Çünkü sizin için değilse karşı
taraf için bu çok değerli ve hep aklım
bir yerinde bu hikaye vardı Ben dedim ki
biz bir proje yapalım Ebru'ya
anlatıyorum bunu bir proje yapalım ve
insanların pazar Alışverişlerine Market
alışverişlerini yapıp kapılarına teslim
edelim bunu sordum Ebru okey falan dedi
Biz birkaç Şef arkadaşımız da görüştük
Aslında Sektörel olarak ki protip
olduğumuz Ama arkadaş olduğumuz
insanları aradım Dedim ki ya ben
Ya aslında böyle bir proje var Katılmak
ister misiniz annemi başlamış Herkes bir
arayışta evet dedi Birkaç kişi Biz bir
WhatsApp grubu kurduk sonra WhatsApp
grubundan hikayeler dönmeye başladı
Herkes iyi demeye başladı ya işte bir
paraları çalar biri bir şey yapar çünkü
biz What Instagram üzerinden örgütlenip
dijital çağdayız artık Instagram
üzerinden örgütlenip oradan paylaşıp
Mahalleli örgütler kuracağız her
mahallede bir sorumlu olacak o sorunlu
işte kendi çevremizde ya da bize haber
veren insanlardan topladığımız
bilgilerle satın alma yapıp evlerine
teslim edecektik sonra hemen bu kötü
yorumlardan sonra alan iyilik yapmaya
çalışmak Böyle bir sürü kötüye yol
açıyor gibi bir hikaye vazgeçtik bundan
biraz bir süre daha geçti yani bir
günden bahsediyorum ve benim aklıma
yemek yapıp dağıtmak geldi çünkü dedim
ki ya ben zaten şifremi yemek yapıyorum
bütün hayatım boyunca hep yemek yaptın
Baba annem çok iyi yemek yapardı babam
yemek yapar annem ya
bu bitti hayatım bu başka bir şeyim yok
E o zaman ben yemek yapmaya devam edeyim
dedim Peki nasıl olacak E böyle
konuşuyoruz yeni bir WhatsApp grubu
kurduk olumsuzları çıkardık olumlu geri
aldık aramıza E buradan örgütlendi dedi
ki herkes kendi restoranında günde 42-52
yemek yapacağız markalarla görüştük
markalar dediler ki günde iki yüz kişiye
kadar bize destek olacağız büyük market
zincirleri ve saireler ve biz de
yıllardır çalıştığımız için tedarik
zincirlerinde bunlar bize yardım etmeye
başlar yardım etme sözü verince Biz şeyi
kararı aldık Tamam dedik Herkes kendi
mutfağında yapsın örgütler elim bir
Instagram hesabı oluşturduk bu hesabın
adı Sen güvende kal Çünkü 65 yaşın
sokağa çıkma yasağı süreci başlamıştı
dedim ki yani karşıdaki diziyi
düşünüyorum çok güzel bağlarımız var ama
biz gidemiyoruz dükkan Kapalı ve bu
teyze ne yapıyor acaba dedik ya biz
Çünkü her sabah penceresini aç
o zaman merak eder çalardı kapısını
Cennet teyze derdi ki iyi misin Bir şeye
ihtiyacın var mı Çünkü yalnız yaşıyor
duydu derken bu teyzeden yola çıkıp Evet
biz yaşlı En azından yaşı gereği bugün
evinden çıkamayan insanlara bir şey
yapmalıyız diye başlayan Hikayemiz iki
günün içinde Kadıköy Belediye Başkanı
ofisinde bir şekillendi Çünkü İçişleri
Bakanlığının bir Genelgesi gereği
Aslında biz yemek yapıp dağıt
alıyormuşuz Ben zaten Şefim sertifikam
var diplomaların var aslında yemek yapıp
dağıtıyorum Normalde parayla ama parasız
dağıtılmıyor muşum Bunu öğrenince dedi
ki bir kurum bize yardım etmeli ve
Kadıköy Belediyesi'ne gittim aradım
sonra gel görüşelim dedi Gittik
gerçekten genç bir Başkan sağolsun hemen
15 dakikada falan bir şey olduk on beş
dakikanın sonunda şöyleyiz
işte başlıyoruz Peki dedi ki çocuklar
dedi kendi restoranımızda yapmayın Madem
gıda desteği buldunuz ben size yardım
edeyim mutfağa beğenmedim size dağıtım
için ben size ekip oluşturuyorum siz
yapın ve gönülleri getirin ve gıdayı
bulun Tabii ki bizim de markalardan
anlaştığımız günlük 300 kişiydi sonra
Okey dedik biz böyle bir kafa
karışıklığı çıktık Tamam yapıyoruz bu
işe başlıyoruz dedik ama Umut hep biri
ben hep çok inandığım bir şey hayatım
boyunca sonuna kadar götürdüm yapacağız
dedim Hiçbir yolu yok bunu dedim Sonra
bize bir asistan atadılar dediler ki bu
arkadaşımız her şeyimiz den sorumlu ne
soruyorsanız ona sorun dediler biz bazı
Turizm firmalarına aradı dedi ki
insanları sosyal şeyle getiremeyiz toplu
taşıma araçlarıyla getiremeyiz Bize
servis gelin dedik Sonra Instagram
hesabından paylaşımlar yaptı kişisel
hesaplarımızdan da paylaşımlar yapıyoruz
en ama en büyük Korkumuz başladı Biz 3
ay boyunca ya da dört ay boyunca 5
Bu bir sonuna kadar gideceğiz ya bu
kadar gönüllü Nereden bulacağız diye
böyle bir Kaygımız başladı Benim için
beş kişiyi gelmek istemeyen olabilir
korkan var Annesi babası yaşlı ailesiyle
yaşayanlar var bu gönülleri bulur muyuz
kaygısıyla Hepimiz evlerimize gittik ve
beş kişi zaten ilk gün ve Songül hep
böyle oldu evlerimize gittik ve akşama
doğru bir Zoom toplantı dijital
döneminin en önemli şehirlerinden biri
bir Zoom toplantısı yaptık E ben dedim
ki ilk postu ben atacağım bugün gönüllü
aranıyor diye bakalım ne olacak
Gerçekten saat 09.45 falan suları evde
Çok tedirgin kaygılı Çünkü belediye
başkanına mahcup olmak gibi bir
durumumuz da söz konusu Bu kaygıyla bir
Story koydum gönüllü aranıyor arkadaş
diye böyle şey yaptık hani bize yardım
etmek ister misiniz böyle böyle bir
hikayede anlattığım bir Story koydum
yok abi 11'e 11 buçuğa doğru Gerçekten
90'ın üzerinde yönlülüğü destekçi
olmuştu ve o 90'ın üzerinde Gönül
eksilerin hepsi ama hepsi neredeyse aşçı
değillerdir
Sağ üstteki mi Ben ev Kadınıyım Evde de
yemek yapıyorum zaten sizin süslü tabak
kanınızdan yapılmayacak ne olacak
videodu kime isteseydi yordu Ya ben
Ostim falan Şefim ilacı uçtum servis
yapmayı biliyorum herhalde bir İşinize
yarar Imm diyordu biz bu sevinçle Okey
ya Bakın ben hep şey dedim Allah'ım bu
kadar evde çıkmaya Gönüllü gönüllü var
mı dedim hep kendi kendime ve biz bir
sonraki gün belediye başkanının bize
atadığı asistanı arayarak Peki biz ilk
gün kaç kişi yemek Fatih dedik bu da
yaşadığınız çok ikinci şok oldu herhalde
bir çocuğumuz da çünkü biz hepimiz benim
hayat boyu inancım bir restoranda en
fazla 42 yemek yemeli Benim dükkanım 12
kişilik bir dükkan çünkü ben çoklu yemek
servisine inanan bir insan değilim Ben
çoklu yemek servisini sistematik olarak
doğru bulan bir insan değildir yani Şunu
mu demek istiyorsun Şefim ha ha Ben
kazandım yemek hiçbir şey verdim diye
gibi siz böyle
bu kulede Havalı havalı Minicik minicik
böyle Bizim tabağımızda yemekleri bizim
ediyorsunuz porsiyon gramajlama da en
çok yaptığımız ürünü bir kilo yapıyoruz
yani O da böyle bir çok kişiye yetecek
kadar soru Belediye Başkanı zaten
hepimizin kafasına soktu bir soru vardı
dedi ki çocuklar Tamam hepiniz işte
birimiz ye mezunuz birimiz Kordon
mezunuz beş kişiyiz gerçekten peşimizde
ustası mutfak mezunuyum ve dedik ipeksi
hiç Kazan Yemeği yaptınız mı dedi Biz
Tabi o zaman şeklimizi asla laf
ettirmeyiz yani yapmadık dedik ama
yaparız ne olacak falan dedik ama
hepimizin içi içini yiyor Çünkü hiçbir
Biz benim dışında ben biraz aileden
biliyorum O bizde de öyle bir şey yoktu
benim dışında hiç kimsenin daha önce
Kazan görünüşlü yok neredeyse Yani o
kadar büyük Yok öyle bir şey sor biz
böyle düşünüyoruz yaparız herhalde falan
akşam birbirimize diyorsun yaparız
diyoruz tamam mı yaparız ya miktar
varmış da diyor ki Evet yaparız herhalde
der
Ya aslında geldiğimiz yerde biz
kazanlarla 100-120 kiloyu Bunlar
yemekler pişiren bin 200 kişi haberini
alınca şoklar geçiren ama bunu da
yaparız diyen gerçekten umut etmek
inanmak O kadar önemli bir şey ki biz
Umut ettik İnandık ve 3 ay boyunca 40
kişi diye yola çıktığımız hikaye her gün
1200 e iki öğün yemek yani 2400 kişi
yemek yaparak sürdürüldüğü en çok
gönüllü destekçiler de vardı markalar
sonsuz destek oldular markalar ve bayağı
bireysel de insanlar sonsuz destek
oldular Hikaye Böyle devam etti ama
gerçekten şunu gördüm paylaşımı ne kadar
önemli bir şey olduğunu gördüm paylaşmak
ne kadar büyük bir güç müş Aslında onu
gördüm bir araya gelmenin kaygısız bir
araya gelmenin beklentisiz bir araya
gelmenin yüzünü gördüm hayatım boyunca
bir tek pandemi de bir hiç oldu
bu ama bir yandan da o hiçliğin de İnsan
İsterse koca bir de ve dönüşebileceğini
gördüm Her gün televizyon kanallarında
Canlı yayınlarda inanılmaz böyle haber
kanallarında falan konu olduğumuzu
gördüm Şok geçirdim ama çok büyük
gururla hayatım boyunca yaşayacağı bir
şey yaşadım ya Umut Gerçekten sen
Emeğinize sağlık diyeyim insan olmak
biraz da başkalarının dertleriyle
dertlenmek Yani bir şef olmak sadece
yemek pişirmekte değil hasta bize bunu
gösterdiğin için Sana çok çok teşekkür
ediyorum Yüreğinize sağlık Emeğinize
sağlık dün bu ekibe katkı sağlamış
arkadaşlarınıza da buradan sevgilerimizi
gönderiyoruz kötüye Zoom